ever since even before deep learning was
a buzzword or something even many people
were focusing on Google was at the
Forefront easily the company with the
most faith and energy being put into
neural networks including through use in
search results and linking content and
all that but also for things like a
Google Voice Assistant and so on in
terms of deploying AI Into the Wild for
the purposes of making exceptional user
applications Google was truly the leader
in terms of research it also appeared
Google was the overall leader in AI
Google authored the seminal attention is
all you need paper which came out in
2017 and really got the ball rolling for
Transformer models arguably Without
Really anyone even Google
realizing what would come from it for
years and then they also did Bert a
bi-directional encoder representations
from Transformers kind of model
architecture in 2019.
around this time however other companies
began to sort of emerge in the large
language models space which are
generally just big transformers trained
on text and the leader in this space has
turned out to be open Ai and by proxy
Microsoft the sort of IBM of my
generation's era in mid-2019 Microsoft
invested a bit over 1 billion dollars
into openai which came with Azure
compute power for openai as well to make
use of for training models and all of
that a bit earlier in late 2018
Microsoft had also acquired GitHub for
7.5 billion dollars at the time people
even myself included weren't really sure
what to make of this acquisition like
what was Microsoft's Interest really in
open source it was marketed as an
investment into open source but yeah
yeah what are you really going for well
fast forward a bit to Mid 2021 and
GitHub co-pilot is released as a sort of
technical preview GitHub copilot is
nothing more than a GPT style model that
is just simply trained on programming
code
a lot of code basically all of GitHub
GitHub copilot if you're a programmer is
truly a life-changing piece of software
for ten dollars a month most importantly
it works and it works really well it's a
large language application that is just
phenomenally applied to a sort of user
setting not only are the suggestions
really good it's also very fast some
something that people probably most of
the time don't even think much about is
the speed and and how important that is
for usability not just in programming
but in all aspects including search but
making large language models produce
predictions or do inference extremely
quickly like this is a really tough
challenge especially to scale that out
one of the reasons Google was able to
win the search engine game was its speed
and sure results matter but the silent
killer of like any website or app is
response time in late 2022 openai
released the Reese search preview for
chat GPT with a large language model
paired with reinforcement learning based
on human feedback or rlhf openai created
a chatbot style AI an application that
can essentially just do an answer just
about anything you wanted and while
answering doesn't necessarily mean it's
right right it can often be wrong or
coaxed into saying very silly things
there's no question that it's powerful
and insanely addicting to use so
addicting that within two months chatgpt
reached almost 600 million visitors and
100 million of those being unique
visitors making chat GPT the fastest
growing user application
ever it it was really at this point that
people started to wonder is like the age
of a search engine over and are we now
at the age of more like an answer engine
instead obviously this was of great
concern for Google the world's largest
search engine especially when basically
Google's entire existence and Empire is
honestly tied to search it all comes
back to search yes Google does a lot of
other things besides search but search
is really the foundation of much of the
ad Revenue both in terms of ads in
search as well as data from search that
is used in ads in other locations right
now Google dominates the search space
with 85-ish percent of the total Pi of
search traffic
one thing to take note of though is this
pie Google share is either stagnant or a
slowly declining despite being the
default in many applications and in many
browsers and phones and all of that in
the one search engine that appears to be
gaining some steam here is in fact Bing
Microsoft's search engine so when chat
GPT the creation of open AI of which
Microsoft is a very large partner with
is so incredibly powerful helpful and
addicting to use for things that you
would have otherwise used search for
Google is probably extremely concerned
about it as the news of the code red
suggests I've seen people suggest also
that this code red is really just like a
clickbaity thing but I honestly doubt
that if Google isn't extremely concerned
about this then they're simply just like
not paying attention and they're asleep
at the wheel and that's an even bigger
problem
continuing on into 2023 in January news
broke that Microsoft is putting in
another 10 billion dollars into openai
bringing Microsoft stake to 49 along
with Microsoft being set to earn 75 of
all profits until Microsoft makes back
its initial investment and this also
puts the valuation of open AI to 29
billion
as an aside this deal seems extremely
unfair both in valuation for a company
that just produced the fastest growing
application ever
as well as these sort of like Revenue
split and Microsoft recouping their
investment either way though from the
perspective of Microsoft and Bing this
is a huge huge huge win and really when
we look at companies like Google and
Microsoft here who has the most to win
and who has the most to lose looking at
it this way at best Google can really
only hope to maintain where it is right
now it's not going to likely gain a
whole bunch of users by changing to more
of an answer engine approach when people
seek information online they're already
going to Google it's unlikely that the
total users doing search is likely to
increase more than the population rate
is already increasing so at best Google
can just hope to maintain
where they are at worst they lose their
entire business right they go down and
Google's valued at like 1.1 trillion at
the time of my recording this and that
is after losing about 100 billion in the
last few days and we'll get to that in a
minute now for Microsoft
at best Microsoft can hope to become the
new leader in Search and answer earning
them likely a hundred X or more on their
investment
at worst they stand to lose a total of
11 billion dollars
11 billion versus 1.1 trillion
on February 6 2023 Google in a blog post
outlined essentially their commitment to
large language models and to trying to
do what chat GPT has done through their
own variant called Bard which is powered
by Lambda which we've heard much about
for example someone who used to work
with Lambda accusing it of being
sentient possibly but really it's just a
very large language model
unfortunately this blog post from Google
isn't really anything of actual like
substance and in my honest opinion reads
more like a plea to investors to just
please hold on for a little moment
longer the next day February 7th
Microsoft released a blog post outlining
their plans for out implementing a chat
GPT like technology into Bing again this
is just a research preview it's not
necessarily something of substance but I
will argue that being a 49 stakeholder
in open AI
um and chat GPT already existing and
already being deployed and scaled to 100
million unique users but 600 million
total users
um
it's just no question that Microsoft and
openai and chat GPT has already done it
they've already they've already achieved
what is very very hard in a very tough
challenging technological problem I mean
this chat gbt was a free public open
demo that everyone could sign up for so
the fact that they were able to host
this with you know minor outages yes
they have outages from time to time but
again it's free and everybody can just
load up on this thing the fact that
they've scaled it out and it's still
functioning is
really Testament to they're getting it
right
unfortunately for Google one other thing
they did on February 6th was to create
and share an ad for Bard which contained
a question about what discoveries came
from that James Webb Space Telescope and
the answer while looking quite nice and
very confident was factually incorrect
because the jwst was actually not the
first to take photos for example of
exoplanets
not only did the AI confidently share
this information Google themselves
didn't even bother to fact check their
own cherry-picked example that they
wanted to share with the world to show
off Bard because again the public it's
not like this is just a random user
example of oh Bard screwed up no this
was Google's like cherry-picked example
and it wasn't right
um they didn't have to share this one
but they did and it just kind of is
Testament to how sloppy and kind of how
I think you know knocked back on their
heels Google
is at the moment
and again there's no reason to think
that chat GPT could have not made this
exact same mistake it makes tons of
mistakes just like this people show
examples all the time that's that is a
downside to models like this they very
confidently say things that sound true
or sound good but they're not it's just
a large language model all it does is
try to make text that sounds legit so
the problem is though that Google again
Google just has everything to lose they
desperately need to be first to Market
here with a really good
application or at least not be later
than maybe like a few months but at the
same time they obviously can't rush this
and then lose all their credibility Bing
on the other hand kind of has very
little credibility to lose right there
even if Bing lost all of its current
customers they still stand to gain the
85 percent coming over from Google so
it's just Bing can kind of be the more
fun and quirky search engine and get
away with it while it improves over time
Google
can't they just can't so the next few
months or a year or so is going to be
really interesting to watch these
companies just kind of trip over
themselves to outdo each other I'm
totally not ready to say that Google has
like lost and they're just going to die
as a company but they just have so much
downside here and so much risk and
pulling off winning this battle just
simply puts them right back to where
they were when they started it they
can't really get much more dominant for
Microsoft this is a massive breath of
fresh air for them as a company on the
whole they've got a product that just
released and scaled to 600 million users
in two months just that engineering feat
alone is impressive improves that they
have the ability to actually do this
correctly all of that said just like we
can't really say Google has for sure
lost there's really no reason to believe
that Microsoft will for sure win this
either again I think it's going to come
down to things like trust inference
speed and things like limitations for
example one frequent complaint about
chat GPT is how much it's been
restricted since its release
even though it's just open Ai and Bing
and Microsoft they still do have
reputation to lose and I still think
there's room for a more uh unlimited or
unrestricted so to speak chat GPT like
answer engine to enter the space and
really beat out everyone else purely
just because it's more enjoyable to use
and doesn't start so many responses with
the dreaded as a large language model I
cannot and or whatever right one such
example of a new search or answer engine
is something like you.com where you can
just go and chat and chat with an AI
that's very much similar to chat GPT and
it's sort of mixed with search results
and you as a user can kind of up and
down vote answers to help improve it
over time but it definitely feels very
chat gpt-like and at least for now from
my using it I really do kind of like
this application of it another example
of another player is openassistance.io
which is attempting to entirely really
open source and crowdsource a chat GPT
like a i that both is could be hosted or
that you could even run yourself locally
right now things are just simply wild
and I expect while some people recognize
how big this all really is I think many
people are still just missing it we are
nearing the end of an era of search
where you type a query and you have to
click around and kind of read through
websites and deal with all these clunky
ads and stuff like that and maybe find
what you wanted or change your query go
back and instead you're going to just be
getting direct
answers
for the first time in history Google is
seemingly behind the curve here and that
doesn't mean that Google has lost it
just is interesting to see this happen
and also to see Google really kind of
fumble here right
um again with like the ad for example
and they're just trying so hard to
compete and Market against chat GPT
which chat gbt has plenty of of problems
chatgpt is not ready in the slightest
for prime time it's just simply not and
for Google to just be stumbling over
themselves to make all the same mistakes
that Bing will for sure be making if
they go ahead and just release it before
it's ready uh they're just they're
screwing up they're making mistakes and
it's just kind of interesting to see how
nervous Google really is about all of
this and I mean probably it's within
good reason they should be so anyways
like I continue saying over and over
these are very exciting times to be
alive it's fun to watch all of this and
it's fun to just be so involved in Ai
and working in Ai and like watching
stuff like this uh play out I can't wait
to continue playing and seeing what what
other people come up with in terms of
chat EPT like things or even
applications like you.com I'm curious
very curious to see what happens with
openassistant.io and any other players
that come into this space it's just it's
it's very entertaining to be watching
this and it's definitely entertaining
watching Google versus Bing where for
once in a very long time it appears that
Bing might actually have the upper hand
at least for now if you've ever wondered
and wanted to know more about how neural
networks actually work including the
optimization and fitment rather than
just simply calling some method then you
might be interested in checking out the
neural networks from scratchbook by
myself and Daniel kukiwa the book can be
had in the form of an ebook PDF
softcover or hardcover and we ship for
free worldwide also the physical books
just come with an ebook copy all copies
are in full color which helps because
there's a lot of code syntax
highlighting and lots of charts and
diagrams to help convey the principles
also almost all of those charts and
diagrams have QR codes and links that
take you to animations to help further
illustrate the concepts
this is truly a real neural networks
from scratch teaching everything from
the forward pass calculation of loss
back propagation and optimization the
only math that you're expected to know
coming in is basic algebra the rest is
taught by us in the book step by step
everything is shown and explained in the
book first logically then mathematically
then via raw python code no third-party
libraries and then finally optimized via
numpy and this is for every step of the
way building and training actual neural
networks for a fully fundamental
understanding of neural networks and how
they work from scratch if at any point
you're lost or confused all copies of
the book also Grant access to a Google
Docs version of the book where you can
ask your questions in line with the
actual text itself this is an incredible
project that I'm extremely proud of to
share with you all we've sold over 13
000 copies to students all over the
world if you're looking to take your
knowledge of deep learning to the next
level or if you're just looking to start
that Journey I can't imagine a better
way so to learn more and buy yourself a
copy you can head to nnfs.io